any advice on living with a woke brother
who tells me i'm racist
stupid and want people to die because i
don't agree with him
those are the top three insults he uses
can you find a new place to live my god
he's that's
awful i'm sorry i don't know
um you know i
if it were me i think i would point out
um
you know at some point you're going to
realize how wrong that is
and you're just going to be embarrassed
that you ever believed it
and you might invest now
in some thought process that
uh won't leave you
wanting to flee your own skin you know
so you're you're this guy asking the
question speaking to his brother
is that the voice you're using here yeah
okay i'm just saying
you know i think a lot of this stuff is
like it's the right thing to say this
minute to get civilization to turn over
some stuff
and the point is you're just gonna be so
horrified that you ever said those
things because they were never
you know right they were never plausible
and um you know i mean i do wonder
at whatever point this turns around
um i think a lot of people are just
going to pretend that they never said
these things of course they are
uh you know they're going to sanitize
all evidence that they said anything on
social media
and uh if friends or family members are
bold enough to bring it up
they'll say didn't happen yeah actually
you know what maybe that is a
proper approach what i'm very reluctant
to give people
uh advice that makes any of this sound
like it's not dangerous or that there's
something to be done because i worry
that there isn't very much to be done
but maybe the point is you know what
would you write that down for me
i want you to remember that you said
that i want you to know
that when you're saying these kinds of
things somebody is paying attention
and at the point these things turn out
to be yeah
clearly insane and everybody understands
that you're not going to be able to walk
away from them yeah right
and you can do it symmetrically you know
no it's not a trap i will also write
down for you what i think
exactly in fact maybe that's the right
one can we put the two
can we both write what we think read
them
put them in an envelope seal it and you
know if you also want a copy fine but
i'm going to keep it
keep a keep a copy i i i like this
actually it's not
pulling rank the point is look you
really believe that let's write down
what we both believe
and freeze it in place and let's revisit
it yeah now that
um freezing what you think
um really being able to go back to what
you thought at the time
is so critical to um
god does so many things um to do in good
science to being a good friend to being
in a relationship that makes sense to
you know to so many things and it's
nearly impossible because our brains
accommodate to protect us from our own
wrongness and um and they lie on our
behalf yep
yeah that's good i like that yeah
another version of it might be i dare
you to journal it
you you think you've got this all wired
you think you understand how this stuff
works i dare you to journal it and then
just revisit
yeah it doesn't have to involve me you
journal it for yourself and then i want
to see if
then they'll hide it but um no i
actually i
this is absolutely one of the values of
journaling i think you know journaling
in general is
somewhat gendered right it's more likely
to be something that women do than men
and i
and i do and i've done it more and less
at times but you know pretty
consistently throughout my life
and i do go back and
i do find it instructive to know for
sure you know not to say that i was
right then
but i do remember correctly usually um
yes i really did think that then yep
this is like this
this was written contemporaneously uh
with of the other actions that were
happening whatever
so whether or not i was right about it i
am not i have not sanitized my own
memory of how i felt about it then
actually this is the key to
your own thought process being upgraded
is keeping
ruthless track of what you believed and
figuring out whether or not it turned
out to be right
it's not always fun but one does
get better at avoiding the errors if you
spot the pattern